Let's multiply 9 times 8,085.
That should be a pretty fun
little calculation to do.
So like always, let's
just rewrite this.
So I'm going to write the 8,085.
I'm going to write
the 9 right below it
and write our little
multiplication symbol.
And now, we're ready to compute.
So first we can
tackle 9 times 5.
Well, we know that
9 times 5 is 45.
We can write the 5
in the ones place
and carry the 5
to the tens place.
So 9 times 5 is 45.
Now we're ready to
move on to 9 times 8.
And we're going to
calculate 9 times 8
and then add the 4
that we just carried.
So 9 times 8 is 72,
plus the 4 is 76.
So we'll write the 6 right here
the tens place and carry the 7.
Now we are ready to
calculate, and I'm
looking for a suitable color.
9 times 0 100's plus-- and this
is a 7 in the hundreds place,
so that's actually 700.
Or if we're just kind of
going with the computation, 9
times 0 plus 7.
Well, 9 times 0
is 0, plus 7 is 7.
And then, finally, we
have-- and once again, I'm
looking for a suitable
color-- 9 times 8.
This is the last thing
we have to compute.
We already know that
9 times 8 is 72.
And we just write the 72 right
down here, and we're done.
8,085 times 9 is 72,765.
Let's do one more
example just to make sure
that this is really clear
in your brain, at least
the process for doing this.
And I also want you to
think about why this works.
So let's try 7 times 5,396.
And I encourage you to pause it
and try it on your own as well.
I'm going to rewrite
it-- 5,396 times 7.
First, we'll think
about what 7 times 6 is.
We know that's 42.
We'll put the 2
in the ones place.
4 we will carry.
Then we need to concern
ourselves with 7 times 9.
But then, we have to calculate
that and then add the 4.
7 times 9 is 63, plus 4 is 67.
So we put the 7 down
here and carry the 6.
Then we have to worry
about 7 times 3 plus this 6
that we had just
finished carrying.
7 times 3 is 21, plus 6 is 27.
So we'll write the 7 here in the
hundreds place and carry the 2.
And then, finally, we have
7 times 5, which is 35.
But we have to add the 2.
35 plus 2 is 37.
So 5,396 times 7 is 37,772.